a lot of evil is done in the world by
people who can't imagine that they have
any power to hurt anyone
it's their sense that nothing is at
stake in their behavior towards others
that leads them to ignore the rules of
politeness and humanity and to kick
people as if they were plated in armor
they are in this respect paying homage
to childhood
think of the situation of a young child
of perhaps six who has fun mocking a
parent's double chin or the wrinkles
around their eyes
to this child the parent is still in
many ways
an invulnerable deity
they live in a remote impressive world
of work credit cards driving and the
news
how could someone of such stature be
hurt by a comment about their less than
perfect physique by a tiny person who
can't spell properly
but the child is missing the point their
words do hurt
they can make their parents cry in
private
the child simply can't grasp how
desperate and anxious their parent might
be how every morning they might stare
and dismay into the bathroom mirror at
the visible signs of aging that speak to
them relentlessly of a wrongly lived
life
the parent out of dignified generosity
has shielded their child from their own
fragility
and now their child is paying them a
beautiful if misguided compliment
a belief that they are beyond suffering
something related may happen when
employees get together to gossip about
the person they work for
in their imagination the boss is so far
above them that it couldn't possibly
matter what they say about them
it's only when they themselves move to
senior positions that they start to
realize how vulnerable the person in
charge might feel
how completely normal it is to want to
be liked even if you have a seat on the
board and how imperfect your self-esteem
might be
this idea casts a useful light on the
activity of particularly dangerous
people online their venom isn't the
expression of a feeling of power
rather the troll tends to feel like a
medieval vagabond
outside a heavily fortified city hurling
insults and threats at what they take to
be comfortable inhabitants sleeping
behind meters of stone walls lined by
vigilant troops
they want to hurt
but they don't in any way actually
imagine they can that is what renders
them quite so vicious
true kindness may require us to take on
board a very unfamiliar idea however
young we are
however forgotten and ignored we feel we
are
we have a power to cause other people
serious damage
it isn't because we aren't wealthy
or revered in elite circles that we
thereby lose a capacity either to
comfort or to wound strangers
we become properly moral and properly
adult
when we understand that we may all
whoever we may be
ruin someone's day
and on occasion through a few in
cautious and misplaced words
their life
the couple's workbook contains the very
best exercises that any couple can
undertake to help their relationship
function optimally click now to learn
more
you